what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we're going to revisit spider-man
no way home's ending because the
official script has been released online
and it looks like mj might actually
slightly remember who peter parker is
some of you may have read the script
some of you may have not read the script
but there is one particular line that is
very interesting at the very end of
spider-man no way home a line that gives
hope to all of the peter parker and mj
relationship fans peter and mj didn't
get a happy ending but we do know that
there are more spider-man films coming
so is there hope for peter and mj well
according to the script it looks like
there is and it looks like dr strange's
spell might not have been 100
effective but don't worry i'll break
down everything you need to know and
talk about what the possibilities are
moving forward for spider-man and mj and
perhaps maybe a spider-gwen of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel or spider-man videos alright now
the official script for spider-man noway
home was released by deadline.com it's
182 pages and it's pretty epic if you
haven't read it it's really cool there's
a lot of subtle things that aren't said
on camera but are actually shown but the
script can be pretty revealing and what
i want to focus on right here is at the
very end where peter goes to the coffee
shop where mj and ned are now this of
course is after dr strange's spell where
he made everyone forget who peter parker
was everyone including doctor strange mj
ned everyone like dr strange said it
would be as if you never existed so any
trace of peter parker is gone but i'll
actually read some of the script here
and then i'll focus on two particular
lines that could be complete game
changers for the future so i'm going to
pick up right after mj and ned start
talking about mit and then mj goes over
to peter peter says um are you excited
for mit
mj is confused at first but then she
realizes he must have overheard her and
ned mj oh uh right yeah uh yeah actually
i am excited which is weird because i
don't really get excited about things i
kind of expect disappointment peter
because then you'll never actually be
disappointed right and here's the big
line the script then says a flicker of
deja vu on her face then recovering uh
yeah right it just um i don't know it
kind of feels different this time for
some reason okay so this is the first
big part right here this is not said in
the movie obviously because this is just
body language and subtext and it's what
you're supposed to see but is not
actually mentioned but this is actual
confirmation mj has a deja vu feeling
meaning she feels like she's been here
before she feels like this has happened
before she feels like peter is a
familiar person so right away this kind
of gives you hope and it starts to make
you wonder could mj actually recall
everything that she's been through with
peter parker at some point because it
doesn't seem like doctor strange's spell
could be 100 effective here especially
if you consider the second big thing
that we're about to talk about in the
script and keep in mind doctor strange
has botched spells now it was kind of
peter parker's fault but multiverse of
madness is kind of about doctor strange
having done things that he wasn't really
supposed to have done and there really
is no guarantee that his spell is 100
effective on 100 of the people clearly
people like happy and ned it was 100
effective on them but maybe it wasn't on
mj but let's continue to read this
script cutting a bit forward in the
script this is where peter sees the
band-aid on mj's head peter says you
okay and mj says it doesn't really hurt
anymore is there anything else the
script says peter pauses the moment of
truth
but he just shakes his head and smiles
peter uh
no peter tucks his note back into his
pocket and says thank you mj says no
problem peter takes his coffee looks
over at ned then back at mj and says
i'll uh see you around he walks out the
door and here is the huge part it then
says hold on mj meaning the camera
focuses and stays on mj and it says
watching peter go with a lingering sense
of dot dot dot
recognition this is huge and extremely
hopeful for peter and mj fans and for
those who simply just want peter to get
a happy ending now i'm gonna tie this
into spider-man 4 and possibly
spider-gwen and miles morales
now moving forward with spider-man 4 and
the next spider-man trilogy we all
thought that perhaps mj and ned weren't
really going to be in it at the end
peter parker leaves everybody behind and
he is now a traditional peter parker
living in a bad apartment by himself
moving on to a new chapter in his life
and a big thing that people have been
saying well perhaps this leaves the door
open now for gwen stacy to come into the
picture and yes it is definitely
possible that she could be a romantic
interest of peter parker and the new
trilogy however i don't think that's the
way they're going to go because of this
script i think that mj is eventually
going to remember peter parker whether
that is him telling her everything that
happened and she remembers or the spell
somehow gets undone in multiverse of
madness or enough stuff happens to where
doctor strange could remember who peter
is and then undo the spell for certain
people regardless i do think that the
spell was not 100 effective on mj and
eventually she is going to remember
peter parker and i think this will
happen sooner than later in the new
trilogy perhaps maybe even in the first
film maybe second film i think peter
will get his happy ending because i
think miles morales and gwen stacy are
the next two big spider-man figures in
the mcu remember donald glover's
character prowler does exist in the mcu
and in spider-man homecoming he talked
about his nephew who is miles morales
now of course right now they're doing
spider-man across the spider verse where
miles morales and gwen stacy are the
main characters but we as fans know and
sony and marvel studios know that we
want this in live action form miles
already exists in the mcu and i think it
would be really cool if he started out
with spider gwen gwen stacy and we saw
them grow together just like we saw mj
and peter grow together from the
beginning and i do think that we will
actually see spider gwen and peter
parker spider-man together just not in a
romantic way what spider-man no way home
did is completely open up the marvel
cinematic universe and whatever
spider-man sony verse has going on
opened them up to other spider-man
appearing now miles and gwen aren't
variants of peter parker of course but
imagine a movie that doesn't have the
three spider-man in it but has peter
parker spider-man miles morales and gwen
stacy this would be a great way to maybe
not top but be on the same level as
spider-man no way home eventually and i
think this is the route that sony and
marvel studios should actually go peter
parker mentoring miles morales as he
becomes spider-man and gwen stacy as she
becomes spider-gwen ultimately leading
up to the three of them working together
to take on maybe kingpin or the sinister
six a true sinister six which would
eventually lead to peter parker tom
holland's peter parker getting his happy
ending with mj and ned and probably
happy this script right here did show us
that there is hope for mj remembering
who peter parker is and since it said
there is somewhat a sense of recognition
i'm assuming that eventually she will
fully remember peter whether that's
because dr strange's spell wasn't 100
effective or perhaps somehow her love is
just strong enough to break through this
spell whatever it is it looks like mj
will remember and hopefully ned as well
but let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below what do
you think this means do you think mj
will eventually remember who peter is
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you